What do you do to get into character?
What do I do?
I can't give away all my secrets, Maisie.
I like to be as prepared as possible going to work,...
...but then, on the day, throwing that all away...
...and being absolutely spontaneous and in the moment.
This is for you, Willow.
I'd love to know how you psych yourself up before getting on stage.
I usually get really nervous before I go on stage...
...so I try to kind of go into a little meditation.
That always makes me feel so much more grounded and comfortable.
Maisie, how do you balance your double career as an actress and an entrepreneur?
Well Willow, not very easily.
I think I really dedicate my time when I'm on set to being on set.
But in between doing jobs, there's a lot of time...
...and that's usually the time that I tend to fill with my other companies.